coming up on 5 26 on your Monday morning
got a viewer email on one of the worst
kept secrets about a supposedly HOV only
access ramp to the 95 in the far
Northwest Valley drivers in that area oh
I bet you know exactly what I'm talking
about
Deborah writes making that half ramp
from Elkhorn to the South 95 HOV only is
ridiculous we all use it anyway and it
drives me nuts the drivers who choose to
follow the law have to take Elkhorn to
Durango to get on the freeway the
so-called HOV only on off ramps less
than a mile from my house this needs to
be changed and I'm sure many in this
area think the same thing
well Deborah officially both the Nevada
Department of Transportation and the
Nevada State Police Highway Patrol say
all drivers are required to follow the
law meaning any vehicle using those
ramps must have two or more occupants
unofficially both agencies are very well
aware of what's going on there
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone join the drive and you
crazy conversation we are traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com